hey youtubers happy 2017 so there's so
much new awesome stuff dropping this
year between movies and TV shows this is
just going to be a video to let you know
about what's going on most of this stuff
I already do regular videos for but if
you're new to the channel I do weekly
giveaways so be sure to click that Bell
to enable alerts so you don't miss
anything so much stuff to hype so let's
just art with like the really big comic
book movies so the first big comic book
movie of the year is actually Lego
Batman I don't know if you consider that
a comic book movie or not but that's
dropping February 10th I'll probably do
like a review video for it but I'm not
planning on making a ton of Lego Batman
content as you can imagine but the first
big superhero movie is going to be Logan
the new Wolverine movie that drops March
3rd so that's actually coming up pretty
quickly then it's guardians of the
galaxy - May 5th then Wonder Woman is
June 2nd then spider-man homecoming is
fourth of July weekend then Thor
Ragnarok is like right after that at the
end of July like July 28th then Justice
League is November 17th and of course
Star Wars Episode 8 the thing that we've
been waiting for for so long now is
December 15th
so if Marvel and DC own the summer for
the rest of time then Star Wars owns
Christmas in December for the rest of
time in fact they just rescheduled the
Han Solo movie from spring 2018 to that
December weekend that they always
release all their movies so new Star
Wars every year in December for the rest
of time which just sounds like the best
thing ever
like all the creative that they've
released for all these movies so far
especially like Logan which is like a
really small movie in stark contrast to
the previous Wolverine movies in the
other x-men franchise movies just looks
amazing like probably the best treatment
of that character in a movie given the
context now this is like very old man
Logan so when we get closer to that
movie if you haven't read the old man
Logan story I'll explain that I'll be
doing a bunch of Logan's stuff there'll
be a bunch of Wolverine videos because
they're supposed to be like a funny
Deadpool in tag scene it doesn't have
anything to do with the Logan movie but
because Deadpool is so huge right now
Fox wants to remind you that Deadpool is
the thing that they make movies for that
we might not see til 20
18 but like they just want to keep fans
happy because there's no new Deadpool
this year on the DC side of things
Wonder Woman is also like a huge
creative shift from behind the scenes
because it's the beginning of the Jeff
Jones era of DC films
so whatever misgivings you may have had
about other DC movies I feel like Wonder
Woman will be like the shift back in the
right direction now there's been a lot
of talk about the other new films like
Aquaman the Batman movie I just did a
video about that so I had a link at the
end of this but just trying to focus on
the stuff that's happening this year we
can talk about like way further off
Marvel and DC stuff in another video so
on the TV side of things there are like
a lot of returning shows a lot of comic
book stuff is coming back in January but
there's also a bunch of new stuff that
you've never seen before so like the
brand new x-men show this dropping
Legion is on FX so it's not on network
I'm super excited about that it's on the
FX network so it's cable so I'm hoping
that it's just like super graphic super
weird and they can do all the things
that you can't do on Network shows like
agents of shield but that's based on the
Legion character from Marvel Comics who
is sort of like the non-canon son of
Professor X that has many many multiple
personalities each with his own
superpower so like you've seen the
trailer he's the super mutant that gets
stuck in an institution and they weave
in a lot of the x-men lore so I haven't
seen the first episode yet but it seems
like it's going to be really good it's a
Wednesday night show it starts February
8th so it's still a couple weeks away
I'll do like a legion trailer video just
to remind everyone so like a lot of the
stuff that I'm talking about here I
already do videos for so if I'm thrown
like a whole bunch of stuff at you guys
in this video I'll remind you of the
other stuff whenever I post videos for
each of these things
speaking of Marvel though we have all
the Marvel Netflix stuff that's dropping
in it's all brand-new series that you've
never seen before
iron fist drops March 17th that's pretty
much the same weekend that daredevil
season to drop defenders is after that
they have not confirmed when they're
dropping it it could either come during
the summer it could come later in the
year like around the time Luke Cage
dropped in September but the Punisher is
the other thing that they're working on
and it looks like they might finish it
in time to drop it during the
December so if production can stay on
track we might get three new Marvel
Netflix series this year now they are
working on season two of Jessica Jones
the other series like there will be a
daredevil season three but we can talk
more about that when I post more Netflix
videos a lot of you've asked about
agents of shield I don't haven't done a
video in a little while that's coming
back next week and they're actually like
shifting the focus of the show from
Ghost Rider to life model decoys in Aida
so for better or worse like the focus of
the show is going to be changing
fundamentally but that doesn't mean that
Ghost Rider won't be a part of the show
anymore
so I'll do like a trailer video for
agents of shield that'll talk a little
bit more about that but life model
decoys is going to consume the big back
half of the season all of the DC TV
shows on the CW come back in about three
weeks legends of tomorrow is a schedule
change now that's going to be after the
flash on Tuesday nights so there'll be
some more trailer videos for all that
stuff so I'll explain the schedule
change when I post those but legends of
tomorrow is on Tuesdays now instead of
Thursdays that kind of means that the
video schedule is going to change a
little bit during the week a couple
things are going to get shuffled around
but we'll figure it out I'll explain
when I post those videos other big DC
comic book stuff that was confirmed the
Geoff Johns new TV show made it sound
like that was going to drop later this
year so that might not be till like way
at the end of the year we'll wait to
hear more about that once we do I'll do
a new video about it but Young Justice
season 3 is in production they're
figuring it out but because it takes so
long to animate I don't think it's going
to drop till 2018 but it'll probably be
sometime early 2018 so other big stuff
Rick and Morty everyone's freaking out
about it we're season 3 when's it going
to drop why are they radio silent so the
best rumor right now is that it's going
to drop sometime in March it's a Sunday
night Adult Swim show on Cartoon Network
so if you haven't seen I've started
doing videos for Rick and Morty just to
get everybody ready I'll be doing
episode videos when it gets here so it's
absolutely crazy
all of the episodes are on Hulu right
now if you're in the UK or somewhere
else in the world it's probably on
Netflix for you American Gods is another
big huge genre adaptation based on Neil
Gaiman's book he's planning on writing
more that too so the first season
we'll only cover like the first part of
the book it's supposed to drop sometime
early 2017 that could be March that
could be April but it's going to be on
stars inside the United States and then
everywhere else it's going to be on
Amazon so I'll definitely be doing
videos for all that I'm really excited
that's one of my favorite books American
Gods is great if you have the time
definitely check it out or listen to the
audio book it's a great story and then
if you haven't seen it during Christmas
there was this new Guillermo del Toro
show called troll hunters that dropped
that's kind of aimed at younger kids but
it's actually pretty fantastic the way
they leave the mythology Kelsey Grammer
plays a character Tom Hiddleston even
plays a character so they have like this
a list cast all of the episodes are on
Netflix is just part one so they're
animating season two right now so there
will be a troll hunter season two later
this year but it's like my new comfort
food right now during the holidays like
I've already watched it through twice
the episodes are a little bit shorter
though if you're a big fan of Voltron
they're dropping Voltron season two on
Netflix in about two weeks that's being
done by the same team that did a Legend
of Korra so that's sort of like the
early part of the year in like the other
like really big stuff the signposts that
are coming later in the year so if it
all feels like almost too much to hold
in your head right now don't worry I'll
be doing individual bonus videos for all
this stuff like of course I do DC TV I
do Marvel videos so I'll remind people
when stuff is dropping when it's getting
ready to come so I just wanted to do
this video just to remind everybody
about like the really awesome stuff
that's coming all the creative looks
fantastic from all the movie people in
all the different studios I am really
excited about the Logan movie because it
is the rated-r Wolverine movie that you
have been asking for for like the last
ten years it's going to be so awesome
but if there's like a TV show or a movie
that I forgot to put on this list that
you guys are really excited about just
include it in the comments I know you
know people are wondering about Game of
Thrones - that's coming sometime later
in the summer I'm guessing like end of
June early July there'll be seven
episodes don't worry it's just that they
haven't confirmed anything about when
it's dropping or what's going on with it
HBO has been radio silent for a while so
there will be some new Game of Thrones
coming relatively soon but I wanted to
focus on the more definite stuff for
this video so everybody
get hype 2017 is going to be so awesome
I know a lot of you were asking about
them confirming Doctor Strange in thor
ragnarok that'll be my next video so
that'll post Tuesday morning well you
guys wait for that to post you can click
here to learn why everyone's freaking
out about the Batman movie and you can
click here to learn about that new DC TV
show thank you so much for watching 2017
is gonna be awesome I'll see you guys
tonight